unbowed unbent
unbroken
the words of house martel
a promise to our enemies and a challenge
to our lovers
thousands of years ago the warrior queen
nymeria crossed into dorne from esos
fleeing the dragonlords of valyria
after she landed she burned her ships
all ten thousand of them so no cowards
could slink home
what a woman
dornish in spirit before she ever was in
flesh
she was lucky to land in dorne where
powerful women are not locked away in
seps and the beds of old men
my ancestor morse martel saw her and
desired her and proved that where armies
fail a tongue may succeed
wedding his strength to hers his spear
to her son they subdued all his rivals
together
after the tradition of her people house
martel then ruled dorne as princes not
kings
twice the targaryens tried to conquer
dorne with soldiers
twice they failed
only when the dragon kings came bearing
husbands and wives did my ancestors
relent and agreed to join their seven
kingdoms
house martel could have waged war until
the end of days
but how could we resist the peace we
could take to bed
eventually after centuries of courtship
house martel got into bed with the
targaryens
we took king daeron ii and his sister
for our own before they could take each
other and six kingdoms became seven
even now i do not blame my ancestors
one look at those long silver locks
it is not every day a man gets to ride a
dragon
but they soon learn that you can't leap
off a dragon at will
my sister elia she married prince
rhaegar targaryen and became the
princess she already was
in dorne she walked among vipers and
none would bite her
in king's landing she found herself
surrounded by lions
when robert baratheon rebelled against
his rightful king his future
father-in-law tywin lannister ordered
his beast gregor clegane to murder my
sister
along with her helpless children
and men called the lannisters heroes
after the submission of house stark
aegon marched towards old town stealing
himself for another battle
but he found the gates open
with the high septon welcoming him
the pious fool even had the arrogance to
grant what aegon had already won
and anointed the last valyrian as aegon
of house targaryen
first of his name king of the andals and
the first men
lord of the seven kingdoms
and protector of the realm
but while aegon titled himself lord of
the seven kingdoms
in reality he held only six
the seventh dawn had never knelt
visenya had flown into the veil and
returned with its crown
mimicking her sister rhaenys had flown
over the enemy force holding the passes
into dawn and landed in the castle of
its ruling lady princess maria of house
martell
maria was 80 years old fat bald and
blind behind her back many sniggered at
her as the yellow toad of dawn
the beautiful renise probably thought as
much when they met she demanded princess
mary a neil to her brother aegon though
she allowed that on account of mary's
age and health the simple vow of
submission would do
but the princess told the queen that the
targaryens weren't wanted in dawn and no
martel would ever bow bend or break no
matter how badly they burned
renise could have mounted her dragon
right then and roasted maria in the
castle as her brother had done at
harrenhal but whatever she saw in mary's
eyes scared her right back to king's
landing with a dragon's tail between its
legs
after aegon's coronation
rhaenys returned to dawn with aegon and
visenya
and their dragons
but no armies met them in the field and
no lords defied them in their castles
as the dragons approached dawn simply
emptied
house maitel had learned from harrenhal
and the field of fire
the dragons were unbeatable in battle
but wars were more than battles
unopposed aegon claimed dawn for his own
but as soon as he returned to king's
landing his castles were hurled off
towers and his royal garrison vanished
in the desert never to be seen again
except perhaps when the wings change and
the sands cough up old bones and armor
renis returned on meraxis intent on
revenging herself against maria martell
but dawn was no longer empty
the dornish kept maria's promise and
fought even while burning under
dragonflame
and they won
one day a bull pierced the eye of
maraxxus and knocked the dragon out of
the sky
house martel remained unbroken
unlike the unfortunate reigners
in their wrath aegon and visenya set
flame to every castle and city but
sunspear trying to turn the people
against house martel
but the dornish stayed loyal and when
aegon returned to king's landing he
found assassins waiting for him in the
streets of his own capital
if not for visenya the conqueror would
not have enjoyed his conquest for very
long
from then on the king and his family
would be guarded by the seven greatest
knights in the realm
the king's guard when maria died in her
sleep her weak and tired son sued for
peace
but old maria had exhausted aegon as
well
and he granted the request
the targaryen still wanted dawn and
eventually they would have it but not at
the point of a sword
they would buy it the same way great
lords buy anything
with a daughter
before the seven kingdoms
before the iron throne
there was a dorn
twelve thousand years ago the first men
crossed a land bridge from essos to here
of course there were men so they soon
broke it
then while their cousins to the north
built kingdoms the dornish squabbled
over land water and wives
for centuries
until
nymeria a warrior princess in essos she
led a fleet of ten thousand ships across
the narrow sea to dorne
almost all of the petty lords made it
clear that she wasn't welcome
all
but one
morse of house martell
he saw in her as strength too much any
man including his rivals
after she accepted his marriage offer
she set fire to her ships
for 50 leads the coast was bright as day
and in the burning light princess
nymeria
named morse martell
the prince of dorne in the style of her
people
dorne would be her home
or her grave
for many years nymeria and morse waged
war against all rivals the jordaines
black monks corgiles and even their
mighty house ironwood they sent no fewer
than six self-styled kings to the wall
in golden chains
after morse fell in battle nymeria took
command of his armies and united dorne
in two years
she ruled for 27 more and though she
married again those husbands were little
more than counselors and consorts
dorne was nymeria and nymeria was dorne
she survived a dozen attempts on her
life put down two rebellions and threw
back two invasions
and when at last she died her eldest
child succeeded her her daughter not her
son
and dorne followed her because nymeria
had proven that women were equal to men
if not better
centuries later aegon targaryen sought
to unite westeros as nymeria had dorne
the other six kingdoms fell quickly
before his dragons and ambition
when his sister wife rhaenys flew her
dragon south and demanded our surrender
as well princess maria martell warned
i will not fight you
nor will i kneel to you
dorne has no king
tell your brother that
rhaenys threatened that the next time
the targaryens would come with fire and
blood
maria replied
you may burn us my lady but you will not
bend us
break us
or make us bow
this is dorne
you are not wanted here return at your
peril
rhaenys did
and she died
her dragon died
all her soldiers died
eventually her brother the conqueror
conceded that what nymeria had done
he could not undo
generations later another foolish
targaryen invaded dorne
he died as well
eventually we did join the seven
kingdoms but when we wanted and on our
terms
if dragons could not conquer us
why should we fear lions
unbowed unbent
unbroken the words of house martel the
words of dorne
men may forget
but women always remember when we were
divided nymeria united us when we were
invaded maria defended us